in the wake of the texas school shooting
it's unclear if lawmakers will do
anything to tighten gun laws that has
not been the case in other countries
which have experienced mass shootings
holly williams is in london holly good
morning how are people there reacting to
what happened here
well good morning michelle many people
here in the uk feel a special bond with
the u.s and it's painful to see american
children killed like this but a lot of
people i've spoken to here also say
they're mystified they're confused
because here and in other countries
where there's been a massacre the
government brings in tougher gun control
laws and they cannot comprehend why that
doesn't happen in the u.s
16 young children and their teacher have
been shot dead by a gunman at a primary
school near stirling in 1996 the united
kingdom was horrified by the murder of
five and six-year-old children
by a lone shooter i just can't believe
something like this has happened
it was the deadliest mass shooting in
british history
and after a grassroots campaign the
government here banned the private
ownership of all handguns good evening
all australians tonight share the horror
of the port arthur massacre in australia
also in 1996 a lone gunman murdered 35
people
in response the then conservative
australian government banned nearly all
semi-automatic rifles and shotguns
and launched a program to buy back more
than 600 000 weapons from those who
already owned them the greatest civil
right you have is to stay alive staying
alive and being free from random attack
is a far more precious civil right than
owning a gun these are our most popular
firearms in australia in 2015 we found
the nation's tough gun control laws
widely popular even with this gun shop
owner i mean if you were in america
you'd probably sell a lot more guns and
make a lot more money
yeah i suppose sometimes it's not all
about the money
from columbine to sandy hook
and parkland
school shootings have broken the hearts
of americans but there's been no major
change to gun ownership laws in the u.s
we've got a gun lobby and a corporate
gun lobby that has its tentacles so
deeply into our political process dr
jonathan metzel is a sociologist who
told us he's witnessed the gun lobby
pressure u.s politicians into
withholding support for tougher laws the
lesson of those other countries is
really that people came together across
the political divide but were those
countries able to do that because they
don't have powerful gun lobbies 100 yes
definitely yes one of the parkland
survivors called out senator marco rubio
for taking campaign money from the nra
senator rubio can you tell me right now
that you will not accept a single
donation from the nra
and even that didn't change anything
people buy into my agenda
and i do support the second amendment
but in new zealand another mass shooting
in 2019 51 people killed in two mosques
once again prompted legal change outside
the u.s a ban on military-style
semi-automatic weapons and assault
rifles
this week prime minister jacinda ardern
explained how they did it now we have
legitimate needs for guns in our country
for things like pest control and to
protect our biodiversity but you don't
need a military-style semi-automatic
weapon to do that and so we got rid of
them
australia saw gun deaths plummet after
its new laws came into effect and here
in the uk there are so few guns on the
streets that even the police don't
generally carry firearms and ladies
while in the u.s this year there's been
more than one mass shooting a day on
average in other wealthy countries they
are extremely rare
unbelievable i know
yeah people thank you holly people are
looking at us going what is wrong with
the united states of america you know we
are four percent of the population but
42 percent of mass shootings
so much is is being said out there yeah
in social media this one really caught
my eye
let's take a moment to honor the
sacrifice of our brave school children
who lay down their lives to protect our
right to bear arms people are fighting
mad about what has taken place
and you know the question is will
lawmakers hear
their cries yeah and i say again when we
talk about the right to bear arms that
was written at a time when people had
muskets they did not have we have a very
pesky fly in the studio they did not
have assault rifles that were killing
innocent people innocent children good
reporting by holly williams and
reminding all of us obviously of what
has happened elsewhere we'll be right
back